hey everyone Joey here from Geek culture
and today we'll be checking out the
rocket Max Air glasses rookie has been
making AR glasses since about 2018 and
they haven't really gone out of China
that much until now we've seen this pair
of glasses on the internet quite a bit
some people have gotten it as well
YouTube has gotten it but today we'll be
checking out pairing the rocket Max
together with the new Rocket Station
usually people pair this rocket Max
together with a um I would say Nintendo
switch your computer your laptop but
this Rocket Station itself is an Android
TV and you can connect the glasses
directly to it I've never seen this or
tried it yet let's go and give this a
shot and see how it actually goes let's
open up the content start with the
rocket Max first to see what is inside
this is a very hard case in itself the
guys have tried this out a bit this is
my first time so you guys are going to
experience it the same way oh actually
looks like there's a bit of uh it's a
case that goes covered oh okay here we
go so you can see that this is something
that goes on top of it lightly to black
out everything to give you more
immersion you've got speakers here
and buttons as well um we'll see what
these actually do there are adjustable
nose pads
and a cable here for your it looks like
USBC to plug your devices in that's
pretty much it uh let me put it on to
see how it feels like
oh it's not too heavy
standing from the team behind here
Jackie is this is about 75 grams
does it really hold up over time I think
it's all right initially it's not too
heavy it's out just like wearing a bit
of like Oakley glasses or sunglasses
wrap around but I think you look I look
a lot more docky right now right I can't
see if anyone's looking at me so as long
as you don't you're not so
self-conscious I don't think it really
matters you see if I open it up
man I can see you
Frozone from The Incredibles
where's my super suit I think it's not
too bad uh pretty pretty nifty the real
style of the show because the rocket Max
has been up for quite some time it's the
Rocket Station so this is a portable
Android TV device my understanding here
you can have about 5 hours of of battery
life using this while watching your
shows and it also doubles up as a
portable charger
what 5000 milliamp hours over here you
can see Jackie they asked me if this was
proprietary or you can hook it up to
your own TV
from what I know and this is China
they are all things goes man they're all
friendly with everyone I'm pretty sure
if you were to try it could work out as
well I just put it on you don't really
see much happening this is look it feels
like a tower controls home going to add
button itself selectors and this might
be the volume button let's give this a
shot and see how it actually all puts it
together I'm going to go into the box
here and pick out some of the stuff to
see what we have inside HDMI type c most
likely for charging and this looks like
to be the instruction manual let's go
this one side let's take out the HDMI so
what we have here is a mini HDMI we have
not seen this in quite some time usually
it's like USBC to USBC it goes to the
bottom from what I can tell it should
come with fast charging because it
doesn't make sense I mean five hours is
like what if you're traveling on a plane
and you're you hit the entertainment
system on the plane you take this out
and then you've got your own personal
Entertainment System
Android TV so you got to figure out with
the Wi-Fi so are you able to get any uh
files onto this or any movies under this
might be a tricky Prospect whoa
wow
I'm very surprised it's very sharp this
uses Sony micro oleds how do you get
even OLED into this into this uh this
this size here and they're claiming that
this goes up to 600 nits brightness
there is a button toggle here the
brightness you can't really toggle there
are six levels of brightness what I'm
describing has my best to you and it's a
single button it goes down and then it
goes back up to maximum as well on the
right here I was controlling it you can
control the volume there are 10 levels
here that you go through or you can also
control the volume through the rocket
MAX Station Frankly Speaking because
this is the new boy I'm still more
amazed by this but rookie has given
their own I'll say ecosystem of devices
to actually make sure this actually
works well it has anyone who has owned a
Android TV looking at the actual Android
TV UI itself I've got YouTube here okay
I got to figure this out
I feel like oh person here I will try my
best to really describe to you if you
are Android TV you can see you've got
apps at the the menu CS apps on the side
we've got your play next you've got
recommended and then you got all your
towels in the middle the screen is not
like uh it follows you or anything use
what you see is what you get you're
having a monitor right in front of you
think about it that way from what I can
tell right this would be great because
you guys who might be watching uh a TV
in your bedroom maybe you want something
more personal this might be it you don't
have to put a tablet in front of you and
you're watching it and if you force it
you'll the tablet 4 in the face use two
hands yeah you can find use two hands
for activities
if you're juggling between this and it's
looking at the screen here I think there
might be a bit of trickiness you need to
play this like a game console controller
eventually once you know where all the
buttons are it should be pretty
straightforward but otherwise this is a
now that goes left and right up and down
pretty much straightforward and the
middle down is your confirmation button
uh see I'm trying my best to figure this
out this is the red button yes that's
the bad button oh yeah that's a good
thing uh the shading here oh I can see
exactly and the screen here it is still
pretty dim the the screen instead of
what I'm seeing is quite bright and it
takes up most of the screen I got to
really look in the corner here to really
see Jackie in front of me let's go to my
favorite scene
I'm going to tour Ragnarok favorite show
we always use it for our TV reviews guys
go check that out exactly says you can
see why I'm looking at but can you hear
the audio no okay it's very personable
then there's there's no compromise in
terms of the audio itself oh I'm easy
and 50 let me bring it up to 100
I hope you're not hit by dmca
and I can really hear the audio going
from left and right so there's so let's
stay real into this the quality is
frankly quite amazing let's go check out
the Google Play store and what do we
have we have Prime video uh Disney plus
ice I think HBO is in as well Roku 10 is
all in but I do know that right now
Netflix is not available on this from
what I understand from the folks at
Rocket they are applying for Netflix to
be on this platform itself which is very
surprising because it's Android right
and Android TV it should be all in all
in the same place but as I move my head
around everything's a little sharp I'm
not feeling motion sickness in any way
it's all really very good
and pretty much I think most of your
streaming services are all supported
okay mindful that um looking at this
device here there's no like SD card slot
so you might need to definitely figure
out how you're going to get internet in
the air if you want to use this on the
go unlikely that might be the case
honestly so you might be adapted to the
ground and to a Wi-Fi network it's going
to be tricky because when we try to put
this together the idea here was to
figure out if how we're going to
actually capture the the feed itself but
really have to try and you guys have to
trust me that this is
a legitimate device because most AR
devices right or you can see I think the
issue with most VR air devices these
days is that this thing that you strap
onto your face is very heavy this rocket
ecosystem has helped elevate a lot of
those issues so we could use it on the
phone but that doesn't really mean
pretty much anything the true test will
be to plug it into our Rog Airline hand
it to me and I'll give you some thoughts
about it but before that let's go to
today's sponsor if you looking for a
laptop that has both power and
portability look no further than the
Asus Zenbook 14x OLED it features a
large 70 watt hour battery and stunning
Nano Edge 14.5 inch 2.8k 120 hertz OLED
foldable display powered by the latest
13 gen Intel Core I9 CPU and RTX 3050
GPU all packed in a thin 16.9 mm chassis
that only weighs 1.5 kilograms so you
can stay focused at work or play for
more information check out asus.com
right now we have me playing a metal
slug and this is insane the level of
quality I think you guys can see how it
is but it looks even better in the
screen itself this is totally unexpected
and similar to what I said earlier is
that I've been playing I'm playing this
game and I just don't want to stop
okay you you guys can see my performance
what am I doing there is virtually no
lag in between I am performing this as
as best as I can hey we completed the
library
not too bad okay just nice and I'm quite
surprised that I was able to put it off
first time ever never die you know guys
playing this game or the arcade is quite
the coin muncher
audio itself is pretty fantastic I think
we're gonna wrap it up here and we'll go
to our final thoughts next
one of the things that I think about the
Rocket Station itself and the rocket Max
glasses is
I saw the prices on this it's in excess
of 489 US dollars I might get it wrong
but it's around 400 US Dollars just for
these glasses itself quality of these
glasses is incredible considering how
light it is and the systems itself
I think this can go really far and it's
something that I would love to see
rocket continuously to develop it
for you guys early adopters out there
this is actually a very good buy
especially right now if you want to
really give yourself an immersive screen
right from the start straight away I
really enjoyed my experience using it
for the moment for this period of time
and I think that this device can be used
for extended lengths of time as well
that's why rocket came out of the Rocket
Station in the first place because there
is really a lack of content if you do
not let's say have a Rog Ella like we
did or a phone I don't think using a
phone or a laptop with this makes any
sense at all but having this as a
portable device
makes a lot of sense especially maybe
you want to chill in bed or is your own
personal travel device it is something
that is worth considering for the long
run and those are my thoughts about the
row kit Max and the Rocket Station
simple device Android TV plug Studio
rocket Max has a lot more potential if
you plug it to other devices with that
said give us a like share and comment in
the comment section below if you have
any thoughts about this device or if
there are any questions that can help
you answer them if that's it this is
Gerald from Geek culture and check out
more of our videos over here
thank you